it is here these Samsung Galaxy Note
10.1 the fence about getting because I
have the Samsung S 10 plus and it's a
perfect phone I definitely don't need
this but this aura color is so
incredibly beautiful I just knew that
this phone had my name on it
mine is currently in the mail but a huge
thank you to Casey nice tat for letting
me borrow his phone to make this video
he now lives in Los Angeles and we made
this crazy deal on the side of the road
I pulled up he handed me the phone he
sped away it felt like you're doing
something wrong I'm sure you guys all
know Casey but if you don't make sure
you go check out his YouTube channel
I'll put links in the description I'm
not really even able to currently take
advantage of the 5g speeds that this has
but that is something that I'm super
excited to test out and my sister
husband so I'm gonna give her this for a
while to test out the 5g and she can
report back for us it is the note so
obviously it comes with the s-pen and
what's cool about this is the s-pen now
has some really cool gestures so when
you're inside of the camera app you can
do things like this
of course the s-pen is great for taking
notes or doodling but I'm pretty sure
that's mostly what I'm going to use it
for I'm just looking at these colors and
it's hypnotizing this is the note 10
plus 5 G version it has an IP 68 water
resistance which means you can submerge
it in water for 30 minutes of to 1.5
meters it has a six point eight inch
AMOLED display 256 gigs of storage with
12 gigs of RAM but you could also expand
with an SD card up to one terabyte the
rear camera has three different lenses
wide telephoto and ultra wide cameras
much like the STM the front-facing
camera is just the single clear clutch
design which I actually really like this
is a 10 megapixel wide-angle it'll shoot
21 60 at 30 frames a second but the
biggest thing of all in the note 10 plus
is it does never headphone jack why am i
laughing because I haven't had a
headphone jack for years I haven't even
thought about heaven jack like it is
something that didn't even care about
anymore
and everyone's all up in arms and
fussing that no 10 Plus does not have a
headphone jack get over it
we're over it over here us iPhone people
and you'll be fine if you need any help
or suggestions on how to get through
this difficult time I'm here for you
just tweet me
because I also remember Samsung making
fun of Apple for removing one phone jack
I think it's great I think you're brave
Samsung very very brave one of the main
things that I love about Samsung Galaxy
phones is the camera at any time I get a
new phone one of the things that I have
to test out first is the photos and the
video testing out the front-facing video
on the note 10 plus we are we're doing
it doing it
wide-angle regular this is my station
the stance
let's get that wide angles we're really
good that's at me that's the stance I'm
Maddie
you're such a good model wide-angle
Maddie zoom
so right now the chocolate rubbish
you've got regulars is regular ok so
what's it look like zoomed in
I don't know what it looks like that I
already know it's probably pretty close
it's probably way too close for comfort
and then we have wide angle another
thing I want to test out now is the live
focus video oh man what's it look like
just look good so this you can't switch
lenses it's basically just what you got
there's like a halo of not out-of-focus
around you a little bit I think you
adjust it they're seeing it we'll see it
it looks a little better once you save
it and rewatch it but there definitely
is still like that little halo effect
this is also kind of a difficult
background for it to adjust to but all
things considered I think it looks cool
I probably won't be using that very
often just so now we're gonna head to an
adoption center jenna is there
volunteering so maybe we'll see some
puppies there that you guys can adopt
I'll put a link also in description to
the adoption center if you're interested
we're here at the adoption place and
Jenna's already here oh my god she is a
puppy
[Music]
thank you for watching this is just a
quick look at the new note 10 plus the
stone is really beautiful even though
I'm a huge iPhone fan I've always been
such a huge fan of the Galaxy phones so
look for more content featuring this
phone soon and I will see you guys in my
next video don't forget to subscribe and
like this video hit the bell and do all
the things that youtubers tell you guys
to do at the end of their videos bye